hey guys my name is uh LAN right why'd
you say like that I don't know um we're
gonna watch another YouTube video today
called a Harry Potter versus Twilight
dance battle yes I'm excited about it
cuz I love Harry Potter I love Harry
Potter - I was like so she say I love
Twilight and then we could have a battle
I'm more of a Twilight fan
I think Twilight's I think you Team
Edward or Team Jacob
um I'm team Jacob yeah I love his body
so desirable [ __ ] Taylor Lautner damn
and suck that [ __ ] I neither have you
seen videos of Taylor Lautner when he
was younger cuz he used to do like
martial arts yeah he's kidding
he's also got some good tricks at
weapons yeah damn I know bill is [ __ ]
and not to mention one of the best young
hackers yep to take it that's a the
seriously anyway um yeah I want to see
this video Twilight a Harry Potter
battle each other out I hope it starts
at scared come on why are you taking us
Oh what are these
- sorry what she said what are you doing
in our forest Sackhoff that pile this is
awful
well Hagrid looks like there's only one
way to settle this
back up to them so no was uh now you in
Ward rear up time to brandy
these ain't big enough for you now you
see my face
no visible
Oh what are you doing here
what mom Renesmee you know what to do
Wow
while I dancers are better
you
haha not God jendi you're my boy oh nice
to see you again
you sure know how to shut a party out
I'm you like while I definitely won that
battle yeah I feel like Twilight
actually got more dance time than the
Harry Potter team so I feel like the
people that made this video are Twilight
wanted Twilight to win yeah and I don't
think that's very fair
no I mean it kind of is bad it because
yeah Twilight sucks yeah so let's be
honest Harry Potter demolished the
toilet series yeah no it did and they
should have done it in the dance battle
too yeah I kind of wished that it like
the rapping in the background
and they had wands and stuff but i wish
that the dancing was more related to the
movies yeah yeah they could have made it
more fun and the rapping could have been
worked yeah in tune - yeah yeah i mean
still a fun little video it was very fun
but you know it could have been like
more choreographed - actually yeah the
style was like yeah it was the dance
choreography was like yeah we've seen
that but it's like you know seen some
dance battles that are more I've seen
one-on-one dance bags yeah and Hermione
though what our place for money hot as
[ __ ]
damn dude like to show my wand if you
know what I mean
mmm there's also funny that I feel like
the people they got to be Ron Harry and
Hermione like I'm like okay there that's
Ron
Harry money but the Bella and Edward and
Jacob I was like they don't look like
yeah Jacob especially it was like 6 feet
tall and and like they're not yeah but
yeah fun video fun video glad I saw it
Glen I'm catching up on the youtube vids
yeah I'm glad I have the beautiful
Lauren gob with me to catch up on these
videos anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe right here God
where was it he sits up there it's up
here somewhere he like puts it like Fred
yeah like to have a cover my head a
little bit Lauren's button is right here
for her channel my channel
it's a great channel great channel no
thanks yeah yeah we're Madonna shout
outs shut up Ricky Rushton hey Ricky
give me a shout-out if you want to see
guardians of the galaxy galaxy galaxy
Thank You Love thanks love you guys yeah
I want to see garden to the galaxy come
out yeah just a couple weeks actually
huh
so shout out to you Ricky love you buddy
I would love to do things to your Ricky
Dicky it rhymes with it does the run
yeah that dad so that's why I said it
Ricky Dicky lickity lickilicky Mickey
Hickey do you want me to give you two
some privacy
maybe he said private see who's close
just close
Ricky you're making things uncomfortable
caper boy hey I'm a person can i get a
shout out
actually it's hey my person can I get a
shout out because there's no punctuation
you still put a question mark at the end
of Alan hey I'm everything and I get it
out that's better uh gamer boy hey game
boy
dude gamer but why you stay on my mind
you fulfilling my fantasies I know
you're making fun of me but that wasn't
that bad
you can dance to you can't you yeah okay
dancing did you do tap hip hop really
room the minor moves you do on this
couch are pretty good yeah see you got
your whole body move there you go there
you go Lauren
dance was for you gamer boy that's the
gamer boy dance gamer boy gamer boy leia
di diag knee lei lei diag knee shout out
please at the one and only Ben oh the
guy got excited thinking it was a girl
but is your name Ben or is it what's
your name
I don't get it I think his name is lit I
think his youtube name is lei but his
actual name is Ben because we're
shouting out to the one and only
but there's multiple beds so I don't
think you're the one and only yeah you
can't be the one or only that's just not
following one of many men yeah dude
you're well your request is just
ridiculous there has to be more than one
man out there you know some beds
really already that good-looking not
ones that are coming to mind have you uh
what if one of those bends is watching
this they're not your friends watch the
channel I wouldn't say that more close
but I know people that are named bad so
you never dated have been what about
this man when you give him a shot
probably get the seal ooh yeah yeah I
would hire would need more information
go on Lauren's channel she has a video
called five qualities she finds most
attractive in a guy any app study up
practice that way when you meet Lauren
you're the package that's ready my
friend it's like a little gift bag
usually you should fed extra self inside
of a big box today I don't know I would
let you do that they wouldn't let you I
don't even like defend yourself that
would be [ __ ] cool though if you
could that would be cool yeah I've been
a great surprise
can you imagine me prom askings haha
there would be that method
yeah no that'd be Germany without like
proposals you know yeah asking to go the
prom yeah but people make a big deal out
of that so that would be fun I never
went to prom then would you have a good
prom
I actually a great problem we didn't
have prom at my school until my senior
year of high school we used to have
these two separate parties called senior
men's and senior girls that were the
parties thrown by the senior men the
scream world my junior year there's a
girl that she like was really drunk and
punched a cop oh wow yeah and so then
they took away our senior meds and
senior girls and said that we're going
to have a prom in the school gymnasium
things worked and we were not excited
about it but you know I actually had a
really good time that's good that's good
what a lucky guy got to go with you huh
I actually with my friend Amanda what
the guy didn't go with we were on the we
were the first couple on the dance floor
which was like a prize they gave and
they wouldn't give it to us
bastards yeah I was home-schooled so my
prom um had a great time my mom and dad
dancing in your living room they didn't
allow me to dance in my home it's like
Footloose no dancing allowed my home was
exactly like Footloose that's the best
way to describe it huh cool anyway then
I know we haven't been focusing on here
but showered out